france inter
léa c'est lui nicolas demorand le 7 9 et
avec léa salamé nous recevons ce matin
le président du modem maire de pau haut
commissaire au plan questions et
réactions amis auditeurs au 01 45 24 7
milles et sur l'application de france
inter françois bayrou bonjour bonjour
bonjour et merci d'être un autre micro
ce matin avant de voir avec vous comment
il sera en pratique possible de
gouverner la france dans les semaines et
les mois qui viennent commençons par le
séisme politique des législatives deux
mois après l'avoir élu président de la
république les français n'ont donc pas
donné de majorité absolue à emmanuel
macron pourquoi selon vous françois
bayrou qu'est-ce qui a déraillé
les français ont envoyé un message et
c'est un message extrêmement fort
il ya bien des égards violent
c'est un message qui signifie qu'ils
veulent que la manière de gouverner la
méthode de gouvernement la démarche de
gouvernement change en france
et comme vous savez je me suis battu
beaucoup pour pour aller dans ce sens là
depuis des années
pourquoi parce que
les français veulent et maintenant exige
que toutes les sensibilités du pays
soient représentés
et que chacun soit respecté à la mesure
de ce qu'il est d'accord ça c'est
quelque chose que vous dites depuis très
longtemps françois bayrou et ont dû
vérifier maintenant et on va en parler
la grosse partie de l'interview va
porter sur qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant la france était le gouvernail
mais d'abord on voudrait comprendre
pourquoi vous en êtes vous le camp de la
majorité présidentielle france qui était
la majorité présidentielle on est arrivé
là on est quand même à une majorité
relative très basses même dans les dents
les pires sondages on voyait pas de 245
députés seulement pour votre camp s
contre nous il ya beaucoup de choses il
ya beaucoup de choses que les sondages
n'ont pas vu les sondages n'ont pas vu
là la progression du rassemblement
national il disait le contraire parce
qu'ils ont été comme beaucoup de gens
abuser par les médias le temps de
présence de jean-luc mélenchon et de la
nue pèse sur les médias était telle
qu'on n'a pas vue l'autre côté du prisme
alors je réponds à la question
précisément la question c'est est-ce que
c'est un échec personnel des manuels
makoun c'était pas la question c'est ce
qui s'est passé alors il ya un message
du pays au président de la république
pas la peine de dire le contraire est un
message du pays au président de la
république qui est nous voulons être
mieux prises en compte
et nous voulons comprendre mieux qu'on
nous explique mieux qu'on nous dise
mieux ce que ce qu'il est nécessaire de
faire et peut-être y at-il eu toute une
période pendant laquelle les français
n'ont pas bien vu ça je pense qu'ils
l'ont mal vécu
je pense que le président de la
république est absolument conscient de
sa clique et il a entendu le message
personnel à ce jeu soit je suis persuadé
que oui en tout cas de
le sentiment que j'ai eu en parlant avec
lui c'est que oui et c'est nécessaire
on ne peut pas ignorer ce genre de
message alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire deux choses nous sommes
dans un temps de crise avec une
assemblée qu'on dirait ingouvernable que
les que les politologues habituel
introuvable les
commentateurs habituels
considérerait comme ingouvernable
ingouvernable au sens d'autrefois au
sens où il suffisait de claquer des
doigts au sommet de l'état pour que les
députés lève la main que ce soit adopté
selva 57
non c'était sympa n'entendant 60 ans
ouais avec des avec des nuances nom se
sent beaucoup de nuances sauf une fois
qu'en réalité rend n'a pas eu la
majorité et que michel rocard était
obligé de négocier ou de discuter avec
nous pour chacun de tes textes mais
autrement c'était ça ça a changé
et d'une certaine manière il est bien
que ça ait changé
pour la question centrale est ce que les
citoyens les français peuvent adhérer à
l'action publique et dans la crise où
nous sommes parce que ce que je ne veux
pas je ne voudrais pas qu'on oublie
c'est la gravité de la crise qu'on est
en train de traverser pas la crise
politique avec les difficultés à
l'assemblée mais la crise mondiale avec
la guerre en ukraine avec l'inflation
avec les difficultés propres de la
france qui sont particulières et qu'il
faut encore encore un mot françois
bayrou sur ces figures de premier plan
de la ma chronique qui ont été battus
christophe castaner richard ferrand jean
michel blanquer amélie de montchalin et
puis patrick mignola qui présentait
présidée par dans le groupe modem de
l'assemblée
l'échec de ces figures dit quoi là
encore quel message envoie les électeurs
non mais c'est évident que dans des
circonscriptions de gauche avec la
poussée de la du ps je sais jamais ce
qu'on dit
avec 7 avec 7 pouces et là c'est évident
que c'est devenu beaucoup plus difficile
pour eux qu'ils étaient des figures qui
ont cristallisé une partie de ce message
envoyé et c'est à la fois 13 a juste
pour eux parce que c'était parmi les
plus les plus brillants et les plus
présents de la majorité dont le mandat
vient de s'achever encore une question
sur le constat avant de se projeter
comment vous expliquer le score du
rassemblement national fait entrer au
score historique 89 députés à
l'assemblée c'est du jamais vu qu'est ce
que cette poussée du rn exprimé en
premier vous votre part vous avez
entendu
vous avez entendu la gauche qui vous
accusent de ne pas avoir des consignes
de vote très clair et eux mais
vous pouvez répondre et mais au delà de
la politique politicienne il ya toujours
cette promesse d' emmanuel macron le
soir du louvre il ya cinq ans je ferai
avec moi je ferai baisser les extrêmes
on n'y est pas on y est on y est on est
on est même je peux même dire qu'on n'a
jamais été oui aussi à
mon propos n'est pas de nier les
difficultés et les échecs dans
lesquelles nous sommes mon propos est
exactement de comprendre vous dites
qu'est ce qui se passe avec cette
poussée des deux extrêmes ben c'est
extrême jeu je crois que vous faites des
gestes mais je sais pas ce que ça vient
c'est le langage est
donc
cette poussée des extrêmes elle a une
signification précise c'est qu'une
partie des français sont en ces sessions
sont en rupture avec le pouvoir
habituels tels qu ils s'étaient établis
depuis des décennies c'est cette rupture
qui est l'ennemi principal que nous
devons combattre il nous faut retrouver
le lien que les français citoyens
doivent avoir avec ceux qui les
représentent d'une certaine manière on a
fait un pas dans cette direction ça va
être extrêmement difficile mais la
certitude qui est la mienne et que
chacun doit prendre ses responsabilités
meyer et she françois bayrou qui sont
tout de même étonnant 18 % des électeurs
d'emmanuel macron voter est reine dans
les second tour nuque contraire est né
près de 70% se sont abstenus est ce que
le front républicain le réflexe
républicain est mort notamment chez vos
électeurs les frontières habituelles ont
été effacés vous savez bien que le score
final est due à une chose un report
massif des électeurs du front national
sur nuque et un report vous entendez le
front national de l'extrême droite sur
l'extrême gauche et un report massif
symétrique de nub sur le front national
c'est ça qui s'est passé et kick et qui
indique où qui a fait le résultat que
nous avons
aujourd'hui sous les yeux je ne
m'attache pas aux histoires d'étiquettes
j'essaie de comprendre ce qui est le
plus grave le plus grave c'est que une
très grande partie du pays ne se
retrouve plus dans la manière dont les
institutions fonctionnent et il revient
à ceux qui sont en situation de
responsabilité dans la majorité ou dans
l'opposition
je ne fais pas de différence là on y va
parce qu'il est d'en parler et il
revient non mais il revient à ceux qui
sont en responsabilité
de faire naître cette nouvelle démarche
politique alors commençons par le
commencement la france est-elle
aujourd'hui ingouvernable considérant ce
qu'est cette nouvelle assemblée
si c'est avec les règles d'autres fois
elle est ingouvernable
et c'est quoi les nouvelles règles et si
c'est avec un esprit nouveau alors elle
redevient gouvernable j'ai dit hier en
sortant du bureau du président de la
république nous avons une chose à faire
c'est nous approcher aussi près que
possible de l'union nationale qu'est ce
que je veux dire il y aura pas d'union
nationale l'idée que tous les partis
vont se mettre autour de la table pour
dire aller chacun va prendre sa part et
on va sauver le pays ensemble qui est un
idéal que je trouverai bon mais je suis
assez expérimenté pour savoir que bon
c'est pas toujours vrai
toujours dans la veine du helmand bien
sûr 24 heures peut-être on devrait
bouger un peu véreux et le vernis ça
serait pas inintéressant et donc 7
nous avons tous une responsabilité
cette responsabilité elle ne s'exercera
pas parent embrassons nous folleville
général
il n'y aura pas des embrassades qui vont
nous permettre
il y aura je l'espère un gouvernement
dont la responsabilité sera de permettre
des soutiens et des influences de
permettre des soutiens venus d'au delà
des frontières il en faut plusieurs
dizaines une quarantaine de sièges qui
disent mot ce texte nous intéresse
et permettre aussi que ceux qui peuvent
soutenir puisse influencer
autrement dit il va falloir mettre des
mots plus autrement dit non non là vous
êtes le souverainisme non non pas du
tout je vais vous donner un exemple la
russie d ouverture de discussions avec
les formations politiques qui ne sont
pas dans la majorité et leurs
représentants à l'assemblée pour qu' il
puisse inspirer une partie des textes et
soutenir les textes je vais vous donner
un exemple précis la rallye on a un
texte qui a été adopté comme ça dans les
années précédentes c'est la loi qu'on
appelle macron sur l'économie
réelle macron était alors ministre de
l'économie il a présenté une loi qui
était très controversé devant
l'assemblée nationale il à discuter
dialoguer négocier avec les uns et les
autres pour que le texte final
deviennent acceptables et soit adopté on
n'a qu'à faire ça on va on va on va
j'espère faire en sorte que les
gouvernements ne cherche plus à imposer
leurs textes mais cherche à proposer un
texte et que ces textes puissent aller
dans le sens de l'intérêt général
autrement y aura crise et si la crise il
y aura évidemment la rupture pour qu'on
essaie de vous comprendre un
gouvernement qui s'approche je reprends
vos moore un gouvernement qui s'approche
au plus près de ce que serait l'union
nationale ce serait jusqu'où doua où
vous voyez un gouvernement avec quoi dlr
évidemment vous allez me dire oui mais
ça irait quoi de fabien roussel à
aurélien pradié est-ce que ça irait
jusqu'à jordan bardella non mais
expliquez nous
ce genre de schéma un peu caricatural ce
n'est pas de votre faute c'est comme ça
ne marche pas
ça n'est pas il n'y aura pas l'adhésion
des partis qui sont aujourd'hui dans
l'opposition à la majorité et d'ailleurs
je pense pas qu'on puisse leur imposer
il faut respecter ce qu'ils sont on peut
tout à fait respecter les différences et
les divergences et cependant travailler
avec eux à améliorer les textes s'ils
sont améliorable je pense pas que les
gouvernements aient toujours raison je
pense que parfois l'opposition a raison
on ne peut vous comprenez ce qu'on va
vivre et sans précédent les crises dans
lesquels nous entrons sont sans
précédent et croire qu'on va y aller
simplement en imposant son point de vue
ça ne marchera pas c'est une manière on
a besoin
on a besoin que le gouvernement prenne
en compte les oppositions et les dans
les oppositions il y a probablement à
retenir lorsqu'on a un texte à adapter
escient jacob a dit hier clairement sans
honneur sans ambiguïté à notre micro pas
d'accord de gouvernement c'est
exactement ce que l'aja nous permet de
vous dire avec emmanuel macron donc du
cas par cas du cas par cas du cas par
cas selon k selon les textes tous les
problèmes tous les textes qui vont
proposer des solutions aux difficultés
du pays sont à examiner avec la majorité
et avec des oppositions et avant les
textes il fois il faut des incarnations
il faut un gouvernement quand vous
parlez du gouvernement d'union nationale
c'est quoi c'est uniquement la majorité
relative que vous avez ça c'est à dire
je n'ai pas dit d'union nationale ce qui
se rapproche le plus près de 20 millions
nationale je reprends vos termes mais
est-ce à dire quoi que vous allez qu'il
faut donner des gages mais des
incarnations venant d'autres parcs de
ceux de cette major il faut rester et
non mais pour qu'on comprenne cela
envers le gouvernement actuel avec
elisabeth bornes et les ministres qui
font qu'ils sont issus de l'ancienne
majorité présidentielle et ensuite vous
irez négociés au cas par cas avec les
différents groupes de l'assemblée
nationale ou est-ce que dès maintenant
dès la semaine prochaine quand il va
annoncer probablement son son
gouvernement et de son ca ou son nouveau
premier ministre à elisabeth bornes où
je sais pas est-ce que vous il faut des
personnalités venues sur d'ailleurs oui
bien sûr le général de gaulle a défini
une fois pour toute et ya très longtemps
ce que serait la cinquième république il
a fait ça dans un discours célèbre vous
êtes une spécialiste qui est le discours
de bayeux et à bayeux juste après la
guerre le général de gaulle qui venait
de quitter le pouvoir a dit une chose
très simple il a dit
nous allons enlever
l'exécutif aux manoeuvres parlementaires
aux histoires de partie c'est le
président de la république nommera le
gouvernement écoutez bien ouvrez les
guillemets en tenant compte des nuances
de l'assemblée nationale eh bien il
suffit et il faut faire cela tenir
compte de la composition de l'assemblée
nationale jusqu'au rassemblement de
trouver des personnalités qui puisse
d'une certaine manière porter une partie
du message de la majorité bien entendu
et des sensibilités qu'on a vue former
un gouvernement et prendre à bras le
corps les sujets qui s'impose parce que
les sujets qui s'impose ne sont pas des
sujets politiques avec cours ou sans le
rn bas avec ou sans nulle biron non avec
ou sans le rmi diront non avec ou sans
les appareils de partis d'opposition ils
diront non tout le monde personne n'est
à la recherche d'un accord de coalition
mais la certitude c'est que nous avons
besoin de montrer que le rapport entre
les gouvernants et le pays a changé avec
cette élection législative avec le
chapeau arn ou le chapeau nu puisque à
vous les mettez quand on vous pose des
reines vous nous dites nuque mais avec
des personnalités de l'assemblée
nationale
eh bien non mais parce que je vous pose
la question parce qu'à l'instant clément
bonne dit il ne peut pas y avoir
d'alliance même de circonstance avec le
rassemblement ce que ce que je vous dis
donc c'est pas très bas 6,7 c'est d'une
clarté bible il n'y aura pas d'accord
d'appareil oui d'accord mais par exemple
pas qu'à l'assemblée nationale quelqu'un
venant du rassemblement national est ce
que vous le preniez dans le gouvernement
d'union nationale mais quelqu'un venant
de la nuque de d1 soumis est-ce qu'il
peut rentrer il ne voudra pas quelqu'un
qui est de la nuque ou du rassemblement
national ne le voudra pas ne cherchons
pas des choses artificielle donc alors
prenons quelque chose fabien roussel il
a dit en sortant du bureau du président
a fui comme vous que le président lui
avait parlé d'un évent d'une éventuelle
union nationale et qui n'est pas
totalement fermée quelqu'un comme fabien
roussel pourrait rendre quelqu'un mais
pas totalement fermée on regarde avait
oui ce qu'il peut apporter à une
majorité moi je ne classe pas les gens
selon leur étiquette je classe les gens
selon le selon le fond de ce qu'il pense
de ce qu'ils valent et de ce qu'ils
disent le temps est venu de tenir compte
de toutes les sensibilités du pays pour
que le pays se reconnaissent en
reviennent à se reconnaître enfin dans
la manière dont il est gouverné ce
serait un gouvernement d'union nationale
ou un gouvernement d'immobilisme
quand on veut le temps que vous mettez à
nous expliquer l'ambré requis des
prérequis des prérequis
ça va déboucher sur quoi eux votre thèse
c'est que ça n'est pas gouvernable sais
c'est qu'une balle annoncé votre c'est
une question non c'est de nouveau
question la thèse que vous essayez de
défendre alors mettons les hypothèses
voilà c'est plus interview
contradictoire c'est un troll c'est que
ça n'est pas gouvernable qu'on va à la
catastrophe et que donc il vaut mieux
plier les gaules on sait qu'on voudrait
beaucoup mon sentiment tel n'est pas mon
sentiment je suis pour un gouvernement
qui agissent en tenant compte des
sensibilités du pays parce que le pays
est en rupture avec ses gouvernants et
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui qu'il est en
rupture avec ses gouvernants il ya
trente ans qu'il est en rupture avec ses
gouvernants il ya trente ans qu'il ne se
reconnaît plus et donc le l'idée qu'il
suffirait d'accepter que bon c'est fichu
est une idée qui n'est pas la mienne moi
je suis quelqu'un qui croit qu'on peut
construire qu'on peut agir qu'on plonge
et qu'on n'est pas obligé on peut par le
bien le réer 2e laisser tomber les bras
longs peu parlons bien françois bayrou à
terme est ce qu'il ya une autre solution
que de dissoudre est ce tenable ce que
vous décrivez est nappe pendant cinq ans
mais je pense que c'est difficile
mais qu'on peut le faire cinq ans et que
si on ne le fait pas on va à la
catastrophe
vous voyez pas que c'est une rupture de
plus en plus graves chaque fois à chaque
élection la rupture est plus grave que
l'élection précédente l'abstention est
plus grave qu'à l'élection précédente
alors il ya des gens qui veulent
continuer comme ça - je n'ai jamais
voulu continuer comme ça je plaide pour
que au contraire on change la manière de
gouverner et qu'on ait enfin ce qui
permettrait une démocratie vivante un
président fort c'est la 5ème république
un parlement fort c'est fait depuis sept
semaines alors ça va être un parlement
agitée mais il est fort et un
gouvernement fort avec un premier
ministre fort avec un premier ministre
qui fasse son boulot ou une première
ministre qui fasse son boulot de chef
elizabeth bornes peut-elle rester à
matignon dans votre compte c'est la
question qui est apposée au président de
la république c'est lui qui feront le
gouvernement c'est ça la différence avec
les régimes type allemand les régimes
type allemand sait que c'est les
appareils de parti qui désigne chef du
gouvernement en france heureusement
c'est le président de la république élu
au suffrage me poser la question
différemment est ce que dans votre
config si ça marche l'union nationale ce
gouvernement dans cette configuration
d'union nationale est ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas un premier ministre très
politique pour des mercières
jeu les beats en faussant fois déjà je
pense que les temps exige que le premier
ministre ou la première mini soit
politique qu'on n'ait pas le sentiment
que c'est la technique qui gouverne le
pays mais au contraire les sentiments
profonds qui s'exprime dans le peuple ça
pourrait être vous
le président de la république en
décidera ben je ne ne suis pas une femme
comme comme ça vous a pas échappé on
passe au standard où nous attend gilles
gilles scandalisé me dit on bonjour
bonjour bonjour je suis effectivement
scandalisé par le double langage tenus
par monsieur b rookie d'une d'une voix
parle d'union et de l'autre voie
continue dont le sous texte à
caricaturer le muy besse et à l'envoyer
à la comparer à lemaitre n'ont pas aidé
dit kemal équivalentes sont va dire pour
être précis avec le et rennes alors moi
je suis militant usées
j'étais candidat j'ai senti la farine en
2017 et je ne crois gilles en fait
voulons pas nous parlons des extrêmes
voilà la plaisanterie de petit neveu de
l'extrême centre employés les quelques
temps par un monsieur mac pro b où on
voit ce que j'avais dit achetez un
extrême chante je suis au centre tous
les autres sont des l'ennemi et des gens
pas très comptable or mais son nouveau
coup de la crise actuelle et de le fait
qu'elle s'aggrave on ne peut pas traiter
tous de faire chier royaume uni sinon
c'est vraiment le chaos merci gilles
meystre ouais merci gilles pour cette
analyse du paysage peuvent jouir
exactement le contraire je françois
bayrou je n'ai jamais traité aucun des
courants du pays de en les caricaturant
comme des ennemis je pense au contraire
que chacun doit être entendu si l'on
veut faire que la réconciliation ait
lieu il ya une autre option qui est sur
la table c'est celle défendue par
edouard philippe qui lui dit il faut une
grande coalition
je sais pas s'il précise qu en gros ce
serait avec les l air mais une vraie
grande coalition donc pas l'union
nationale se rapprochait l'union
nationale une grande coalition qu'est ce
que vous en pensez bah si c'était
possible j'examinerai la situation
peut-être le ca va devenir possible je
n'en suis pas certain je pense que les
partis d'opposition viennent de se faire
élire dans une attitude d'opposition au
gouvernement je ne crois pas qu'ils
signeront un accord de coalition je
pense en revanche qu'on peut tenir
compte de ce qu'ils sont sans les
obliger à venir dans la majorité tenir
compte de leurs attentes et de leurs
sensibilités pour faire que là le
gouvernement du pays soit plus
compréhensible et compréhensif de ce
qu'ils sont mais n'est ce pas la fin du
en même temps au fond ces résultats ne
force t-il pas emmanuel macron à assumer
une position de centre droit et a essayé
de joindre les deux bouts d'ongles
question me pose aussi aurélien au
standard mais je ferme la barre antoine
lardon
peut-être qu'on peut le prendre ça
aurait peut-être qu'on peut dire que non
seulement c'est pas la fin du en même
temps mais peut-être que c'est la
réalisation du en même temps sous nos
yeux voulez que je vous dise je pense
que dans les partis d'opposition il ya
des attentes du pays qui sont
réels ils disent des choses et pourquoi
vous auriez besoin de la gauche pardon
je vous pose la question simple là quand
on voit le résultat de la majorité de
l'assemblée nationale on peut penser
comme edouard philippe cau font autant
assumer être un gouvernement de droite
et être de droite non je sais pas
françois verrons je pose la question oui
je vois très bien que vous posez la
question et je vois très bien avec l
idée il se trouve que je ne le crois pas
je ne crois pas que le centre soit la
droite il y a franchement mon premier
jour de ma vie politique que j'ai non
seulement affirmé mme éprouvée et je
vois à votre sourire que vous entendez
ce que je veux dire mais prouver que ça
n'était pas que tous les courants
politiques du pays sont légitimes
autrement dit léa salamé je veux
défendre le pluralisme il ya des gens
qui sont à droite et même très à droite
il ya des gens qui sont dans une droite
plus plus central il ya des gens qui
sont au centre il ya des gens qui sont à
gauche et des gens qui sont écologistes
comme le monsieur qui vient de nous de
nous interpeller il ya des gens qui sont
à l'extrême gauche ils ont le droit d'y
être il n'y a rien d'illégitime dans la
position qui est la leur ce que nous
avons inventé c'est l'harmonie qui va
nous permettre que toutes ses
sensibilités entre dans la symphonie
qu'est la démocratie larmanaye manquera
si c'est toutes ses sensibilités il y en
a cinq ou six toutes ses sensibilités
ont le droit d'exister et ont le droit
de parler et on a le devoir d'en tenir
compte vous comprenez que c'est pas du
tout la même attitude que je viens je la
vérité absolue et tout le monde obéira
c'est plus comme ça que ça va se passer
un mot rapide sur le conseil mayenne
vaincrons l'entente oui
peut-être on sait rien en tout cas mon
boulot à moi c'est de défendre cette
position un dernier mot sur le conseil
national de la refondation
la première réunion devait avoir lieu
aujourd'hui elle a été annulée pensez
vous que dans le nouveau contexte
politique ce projet restera mort-né et
sera enterré non je pense au contraire
que la refondation
on est entré sans conseil les français
les français ont fait c'est s&s à
l'intuition de pronos d'un public qui
avait quelque chose qu'il allait falloir
faire naître les français ont fait que
cet accouchement la l'accouchement d'un
donc exit le conseil d'un d'un nouveau
john d'une nouvelle réflexion et d'une
nouvelle pratique sur le gouvernement
qui tiendra compte de tous ceux qui se
sont légitimement exprimées
l'optimisme des français dans les
derniers mots françois bayrou merci
merci d'avoir été au micro d'inter ce
matin 8h47